el procedimiento de angioplastia
coronaria también se conoce como
intervención coronaria percutánea el
procedimiento se realiza en unos vasos
sanguíneos llamados arterias coronarias
suministran oxígeno al músculo cardíaco
el objetivo es restablecer el flujo
sanguíneo si una sustancia llamada placa
ha estrechado significativamente estos
vasos para comenzar el procedimiento el
médico adormece la piel de la ingle
se inserta una aguja a través de la piel
y dentro de la arteria femoral
a continuación se pasa una guía flexible
a través de la aguja hacia la arteria
después se retira la aguja
se cambia por un tubo pequeño y flexible
llamado funda
esto permite el acceso a la arteria es
posible que sienta presión cuando el
médico inserta la funda pero no la
sentirá moverse dentro de la arteria
a continuación se hace avanzar la guía
hasta el corazón
se pasa un tubo flexible llamado catéter
por la guía hacia las arterias
coronarias
el progreso del procedimiento se
verifica con un dispositivo de rayos x
llamado fluoroscopio en este momento su
médico retira la guía luego el médico
mueve la punta del catéter justo dentro
de la arteria coronaria para examinarla
se inyecta un tinte especial dentro de
la arteria esto le permite al médico
verla mejor con el fluoroscopio el tinte
hace resaltar cualquier obstrucción en
la arteria
si se encuentra una obstrucción
significativa el médico inserta una guía
en la arteria
un globo en la punta del catéter se
mueve a lo largo de la guía hasta la
obstrucción cuando el globo se infla
expande la arteria y mejora el flujo
sanguíneo es posible que sienta alguna
molestia en el pecho mientras esto
sucede después de esto el médico
desinfla y retira el globo
se puede colocar un tubo de malla de
alambre llamado stent en la zona tratada
el stent ayuda a mantener la arteria
coronaria abierta su médico elige el
stent del tamaño adecuado que se
comprime sobre un globo
el stent se desplaza hasta la arteria
sobre la misma guía cuando el globo se
infla el stent se expande y se fija en
su lugar
después de retirar el catéter con el
globo el stent permanece en su lugar
para mantener la arteria abierta al
final del procedimiento la guía se
retira
para obtener más información sobre la
angioplastia coronaria hablé con su
proveedor de atención médica